so the deal's been announced to you know
great fanfare uh 15 billion pounds of
cubic meters this year but that really
pales into insignificance doesn't it
really when you look at the amounts of
oil and gas that the eu is receiving
from russia
definitely this is not a huge amount
compared to what russia is currently
exporting in terms of gas uh it's around
10 but it does help uh start slowly
moving away from this dependence of
europass on russia for all of its energy
supplies
yeah around 10 do you think it's going
to go anyway really to allowing the eu
to impose heavier sanctions on russia
over the ukraine war
well not really because i mean
in one place in in
europe still has a lot of contracts
signed with uh with gasping to supply
gas so they cannot just really stop uh
this contract because they will be going
into uh
arbitration uh but then it does help to
gradually move away so i think this will
help more in the medium term when uh
to diversify the supply of energy into
europe
yeah so it's kind of medium to long term
i guess rather than anything
immediately that it's going to allow
europe to wean itself off the
russian oil and gas i mean that will
obviously be a disappointment to those
ukrainian politicians you know including
the president who have been calling
on europe to do more when it comes to
sanctions obviously there's a lot of
money that they're spending
on gas from russia
yes exactly i mean europe is to be very
careful with the sanctions that they
impose and that's why they have been
holding back at the moment there's
exploring all the alternatives they have
and one of them is to start increasing
lng imports gradually uh but then
there's a lot more that needs to be done
in the long term and and this in any
case will still
imply that
users in europe will have to pay higher
energy prices as europe's try to cut its
dependence on russia
what other options
can europe explore to try and become
more self-sufficient i guess or wean
itself off russia
i mean i think
increasing lng imports is the the most
straightforward but uh so there's enough
regasification capacity across the
continent and there's more plans to
import more lng so this is a safe way to
start
reducing gas supplies from russia and
supporting more international supplies
but then um there's also heavy plans to
invest more on renewable energy and
europe has already been having a big
push on the on the growth of solar and
wind capacity but this means that it
will have to move at an even
faster pace in order to enable europe to
have energy security and not be
dependent on external supplies of any
source so definitely renewable energy is
part of the solution but this also will
take some time in order to uh to build
all the infrastructure that is needed
yeah not a quick fix and what will it
mean in terms of bills you did mention
that um consumers will be expected to
pay more for their energy bills
well i mean yeah like europe is supposed
to pay the highest energy prices for for
the remainder of the year at least
because even if they're diversifying the
supplies of
uh of natural gas um these need to come
at a price i mean europe is competing
against asia for these supplies so then
this creates a price war and that's why
we've seen
this historical higher prices and this
is
expected to remain at least for this
year until we have a bit more uh stable
environment with the in the markets
and of course you know here in the uk as
well we're facing the prospect of
significantly higher bills uh this year
and what's the outlook like for uk
consumers as well
well yeah uk is directly impacted by
this because
gas is the marginal supplies for the
electricity sector so that means that
gas will be setting the price in the
power sector so as long as the gas
prices remain high across europe this
will have a direct impact on the
electricity prices in the uk and across
the
european continent
do you have any idea i mean i know it's
pretty very difficult to how long these
high gas and energy prices could last
for
well at least this year because there's
so much risk in the market that that the
market is pricing in this uh this risk
uh so it's likely to stay at this
historical high level for the remainder
of 2022.
uh gradually maybe they can start
suffering we see a strong decline for
the prices in 2023 for example
uh and then i guess we will also see
more volumes coming into the market in
2023 as like the producers around europe
and africa make a bigger effort to
supply more volumes to europe which
could help stabilize the situation a bit
better
we saw boris johnson the uk prime
minister going to saudi arabia to try
and see if they could release more
supplies and how important are countries
like saudi arabia
for the future
well definitely saudi arabia holds the
key when it comes to oil supplies um not
so much on the for gas but for oil it
could make a difference the opec has
been holding back a bit on increasing
their production but i i guess that they
could also
increase the quotas for for next year
and this could help start replacing some
of this russian volumes into europe